salir de maiduguri la capital de borno
por carretera significa correr el riesgo
de encontrarse con miembros de boko
haram sudan y no duda en hacerlo para
llegar a la aldea de camila a 15
kilómetros de distancia este padre de 14
hijos es un campesino que tuvo que huir
de la región del lago chad desde 2015
vivió de ayudas humanitarias pero hoy
gracias a su trabajo puede alimentar a
su familia por si mismo
cada vez que venimos a cultivar este
campo los agro rangers siempre vienen a
protegernos desde la mañana hasta que
terminemos el trabajo del día se quedan
para asegurarse de que todos estén a
salvo antes de irse por la noche por eso
la mayoría de la gente está volviendo a
trabajar en las tierras de cultivo sin
esta protección la agricultura sería
imposible en borno a la mente muy común
a su mundo
garcía y aquí están los agro rangers
patrullando estos dos centinelas están
bajo la autoridad de la seguridad y la
defensa civil y nigeriana por waka mi
hija ya dirige este pequeño grupo el día
anterior
la llamada fue atacada por boko haram
los insurgentes dejaron una docena de
heridos así que hubo haga misa ya y sus
hombres recorren la zona para proteger y
sobre todo tranquilizar a los campesinos
hacia
el año pasado era difícil que viniéramos
aquí boko haram nos atacaba pero la
calma relativa ha vuelto porque los
ataques no se repiten tanto como antes
sólo ha habido uno o dos ataques este
año ha ganado una nota mucho sonia
boening cuando tratas
redadas secuestros y atentados suicidas
boko haram es el responsable de la
muerte de casi 25.000 civiles en los
últimos 11 años
carla to a cabo es de whatsapp cerca de
la frontera con camerún en agosto de
2014 su pueblo fue invadido por boko
haram entonces declarada capital del
califato por abubakar shekau el grupo
armado más grande de la época durante
esta ocupación los insurgentes
asesinaron al marido y el hijo mayor de
qalá tuvo ella sobrevivió como rehén
durante seis meses fue violada y luego
obligada a casarse con un miembro de
boko haram ahora esta viuda vive libre
en este campo de mike curie y no planea
regresar a su pueblo
boko haram sigue presente en las zonas
rurales nunca está muy lejos incluso
recientemente durante la última fiesta
de edith el kébir los insurgentes fueron
a goza fueron con tres motos y sentaron
el pánico en toda la ciudad e incluso
entre las fuerzas de seguridad
y seamos mi chica es una oficial de
defensa civil nigeriano y encargado de
zona comanda a todos los agro rangers en
un radio de 50 kilómetros alrededor de
maiduguri isaac magnificaba en una
misión a como a mitad de camino entre
dos santuarios de boko haram el bosque
de zámbiza y las islas del lago chad
gone es una de las zonas más peligrosas
porque es uno de los epicentros de la
insurgencia los miembros de boko haram
pasan por aquí todos los días
este es un eje importante para ellos sus
cementerios están cerca de aquí allí
entierran a sus combatientes
rodeado por su guardia el oficialista
continúa el camino a pie se dirige hacia
una explotación agrícola local
importante los agro rangers locales
patrullan las docenas de hectáreas aquí
un centenar de trabajadores agrícolas
produce el sorgo y maíz bajo la
protección de centinelas armados mis
hombres controlan a los campesinos en el
puesto de control donde están los
militares los llaman con la lista
oficial así saben cuánta gente entra en
la explotación agrícola así que al final
del día comprueban el registro y llaman
a cada uno individualmente si una
persona hace falta mis hombres tienen
que asegurarse de que esa persona está a
salvo y puede volver a casa
para asegurar la zona de esta manera los
agro rangers han permitido que los
habitantes de qom regresen a los campos
durante casi un año estos hombres son a
menudo milicianos o cazadores
voluntarios que han sido entrenados
durante algunos meses antes de ser
reclutados por la defensa civil
nigeriana al convertirse en agro rangers
tienen derecho a llevar un arma por ser
oficiales de seguridad pública
antes en la mayoría de nosotros tenía
trabajos manuales algunos perforaban
pozos otros como yo eran mecánicos o
pequeños comerciantes pero desde que
comenzó la insurgencia nos reunimos y
decidimos apoyar al gobernador
involucrándonos en la reanudación de la
agricultura por eso estamos arriesgando
nuestras vidas para expulsar a boko
haram de esta zona para que podamos
tener paz y la gente pueda volver a casa
por la gracia de dios'
en maiduguri el gobernador del estado de
borno ha estado activo durante meses
trabaja por el regreso de decenas de
miles de campesinos y pescadores que
huyeron de las atrocidades de boko haram
espera que el gobierno central
despliegue agro rangers en toda la
región por el momento sólo 5 de las 27
áreas de gobiernos locales en el estado
de borno están cubiertas por estas
fuerzas civiles
estamos estudiando la posibilidad de
reubicar dos o tres comunidades más el
próximo mes y permitir que los
desplazados regresen realmente esperamos
ser capaces de mantener el ímpetu a
finales de 2023 muchos de los
desplazados internos volverán a sus
hogares historia tengo como comenté
sobre tan bajo el espacio que en unos
pocos meses usando rangers se han vuelto
indispensables pero no puede saberse si
también tendrán éxito en la lucha contra
poco jarama a largo plazo
contra